hi there
hi steve
kaufman device removal what does this
say hi there yeah start up again my
computer is doing funny things
steve kaufman here um i posted um
at my blog my blog by the way is called
the linguist on language
and i posted there about uh the views of
stephen krashen about language learning
and i did a video
and uh and podcast which i do
simultaneously
um and then i posted uh about my views
of grammar and and i was
i i don't think i disagree with mr
crashing who also says that there is a
ro a rule you know a role for grammar
learning but it's a very minor one and
and i think it's important to stress
this because much of traditional
language learning places great
importance on grammar instruction and i
pointed out that i believe it's about
one percent of the time that i spend
uh occasionally i'll review grammar
occasionally i'll check on the you know
look up on the website uh on a website
for you know portuguese verbs or
something like that but not very often
mostly i listen and read
and review words and phrases phrases are
pretty key and phrases embody a lot of
the structure and the grammar of a
language
now in response to this
i had a
comment from a person called liam
and he said that in order to
you know be able to use the subjunctive
in spanish
or in order to
in order to be able to handle the
endings of
german adjectives
that
basically we had a choice we could
either memorize the tables and use them
while speaking
constantly referring to them in your
head
or
not learn the grammar and fool yourself
into thinking you're learning the
language naturally which only kids under
the age of five can do with any
proficiency i'm just amazed at how
dogmatic certain people can be
only people under five can do this and
you'll not learn the grammar if you
don't memorize the tables i mean come on
let's get serious here
first of all
everything depends on your goal
now
my goal in learning a language is to be
able to communicate to understand to
understand when the language is spoken
to understand what i'm reading to access
the literature to accumulate vocabulary
and when i have enough vocabulary that i
start to feel this need to speak
to test what i've learned and that's
basically the process it's a it's
basically a snowball gathering speed
down down a long
slope not a very steep slope so it's a
gradual process
and
the subjunctive doesn't matter to me
although quite honestly i find the
subjunctive easier than certain other
aspects of some of the romance languages
uh if i hear it often enough i wish i
were i wish i were type of structure
uh
you know
you must do this in french or in spanish
become subjunctive you kind of figure it
out after a while but even if you don't
get it right there's people who speak
french and don't get the subjective
right and they communicate quite
comfortably and it i think it's a matter
of what you're listening to who you're
listening to what you're reading if you
get enough of the right kind of input i
think in time your brain will figure out
the subjunctive
but there's nothing wrong with spending
15 minutes reading a little grammar book
where they refer to the subjunctive but
you won't retain very much that's the
whole point this deliberate attempt to
study grammar and i've done it i've done
it for german looking at the table
trying to remember the tables it's
impossible i can't do it liam
i speak 10 languages i speak german very
comfortably i've done interviews in
german with podcasters i have
conversations i've done business in
german i read german i have no trouble
with german i make lots of mistakes
probably not as many as i think i do but
i make mistakes and if and i haven't
spoken much german for 15 years now if i
were there and i lived there for six
months
straight
the number of my mistakes would
diminish i would make fewer mistakes
because because of the input that i'm
getting not because i'm studying tables
that's my view
so
if we say that our goal is to
communicate to get enough input
and and certainly all the reading that
i've done on how the brain works would
certainly support the view that the
brain will eventually figure things out
the main thing is not to discourage the
learner and it's precisely because of
the kind of
language teaching methods that liam
proposes that most people do poorly at
school the swedes speak english because
they have so much english around them on
television and elsewhere but it's not
because of what they learn in school
the schools with their emphasis on
language on on on grammar instruction
and memorizing tables they just
frustrate everybody because it's not a
very efficient way to learn for most
people but i don't deny liam that is
probably for you if you like doing it
that way i'm sure it is good for you but
you are in the minority in my experience
the vast majority of people are far
better off to be exposed to a lot of
enjoyable input
at their level that they have selected
struggle a bit
uh with the meaning of some of the words
things are a little bit fuzzy they say
words and phrases they keep doing it
they listen they read they listen many
times and slowly the language comes into
focus
and that is more enjoyable
and a more natural way to learn and that
is not limited to people under five
because i've done it many many times
and
it's interesting the the dogmatic now
some people might say that i'm dogmatic
perhaps i am but i don't deny the
possibility that there are people like
liam but i in my experience i consider
them to be very much the minority and if
i look at
research on how the brain learns things
where it's clear that the brain is
even from an evolutionary perspective is
not at go as good in dealing with
logical explanations
and and and rules presented to it
as it is in naturally identifying
patterns and creating its own rules and
creating its own labels and
making this word located you know with
these neurons and all of the stuff that
the brain does naturally which we are
only beginning to understand but
everything i've read about it suggests
that
the natural way of learning which liam
derives or claims can only be
handled by children under five that
otherwise we're deluding ourselves but
no liam i'm not deluding myself i wonder
how many languages you speak but i have
learned languages without doing it that
way and i know of other people who have
done the same
so that is just a little bit of a
response i decided i thought that liam
was just so dogmatic that i would make a
a
pie